madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
de cette édition à nancy les hooligans
qui ont provoqué hier de violents
incidents
ils ont été autorisés à entrer dans le
stade pour mieux contrôler une décision
qui fait polémique
à beyrouth des centaines de milliers de
manifestants à l'appel du campus iria
réclament la démission du gouvernement
l'armée et la police sont déployées dans
la ville journée mondiale de lutte
contre le sida l'épidémie en progression
continue le sida gagne du terrain près
de 40 millions de personnes vivent
aujourd'hui avec le virus
après la mort de l'ancien espion russe
un deuxième homme aurait été contaminée
par du polonium 210 il s'agit de
l'italien mario ce caramel à qui avait
rencontré l'ex agent secret lie à moi la
plaisance a marché qui ne cesse de se
développer avec au salon nautique et
ouvre demain
la boc des bateaux à moteur de mieux en
mieux équipés le football une nouvelle
fois perdant après les violents
incidents qui ont eu lieu hier à nancy
plusieurs centaines de hooligans du club
néerlandais s'en sont d'abord pris aux
commerces du centre ville avant d'être
regroupés par les forces de l'ordre dans
le stade
seule façon de les canaliser ce soir le
club et les autorités rejettent toute
responsabilité christine beauce
nicolas froemer
la tribune sécurisé est censé contenir
les hooligans hollandais n'aura pas
résisté une demi heure une première
paroi en plexiglas vole en éclats les
stadiers sont débordés par la violence
de certains supporters malgré
l'intervention de 500 crs les sièges
deviennent projectiles l'équipe du
feyenoord rotterdam est mené 3 0 par les
nancéens insupportable pour ses
supporteurs éméchés jets de gaz
lacrymogène le match est interrompu le
stade évacués l'entraîneur hollandais a
beau s'excuser
la fête est gâchée seulement voilà ces
ultras n'aurait jamais dû assister au
match ils sont interdits de stades chez
eux
mais après une série d'incidents au
centre lille les autorités ont choisi
cette option
quand j'ai préféré concentrer ce public
dans la tribune sécurisé qui a entouré
de grilles et de plexiglas et où j'ai pu
les maintenir jusque bien après le match
plutôt que de les laisser
s'agglutiner autour du stade a cumulé de
la frustration
les autorités estiment ainsi avoir évité
le pire
les dirigeants du club hollandais disent
avoir tout fait pour empêcher de tels
incidents
aujourd'hui la victoire avait un goût
amer pour l'as nancy lorraine
voilà et bien préparer ce match pour
éviter tout débordement malheureusement
encore une fois c'est de ce ne sont que
des dégâts matériels entre guillemets et
heureusement qu'il n'y a pas eu de
dégâts corporels et de blessés mais
encore une fois il faut on va tout faire
pour réalité c'est ces barbares des
barbares parquet puis relâché à la fin
du match sous bonne escorte seul set sur
deux mille supporters hollandais ont été
interpellés manifestation monstre à
beyrouth pour tenter de faire tomber le
gouvernement des centaines de milliers
de personnes ont répondu à l'appel du
hezbollah et de la minorité chrétienne
emmenées par le général aoun réclamant
la démission du premier ministre une
démonstration de force des prosyriens
qui bloquent les rues menant au siège du
gouvernement et s'apprêtent à y passer
la nuit
une nouvelle étape dans la crise qui
déchire le liban avec pour toile de fond
l'affrontement entre les pro et les anti
syrien sur place like de la mornais
thooris émane le drapeau jaune du
hezbollah chiite et le drapeau orange du
parti chrétien down au dessus de la
foule
c'est le symbole de ce liban
multiconfessionnel unis dans la
protestation
voici la route qui descend de la région
chrétienne ducassou rouen la semaine
dernière cette même route était bondée
de manifestants chrétiens venus soutenir
le gouvernement après l'assassinât de
pierre gmail aujourd'hui leurs
adversaires veulent faire tomber le
gouvernement
mais ils sont chrétiens eux aussi c'est
tout le paradoxe du liban et dans ce car
ils sentent aoun président nous avons
aussi toi vue nous ne voulons plus ce
gouvernement et nous voulons nous
voulons des élections des élections le
plus tôt possible et nous voulons et
preppy pour afin enfin changer le
président de la république il faut
parcourir plusieurs kilomètres à pied
pour se rendre place des martyrs où des
centaines de milliers de manifestants
sont réunis ça ne pose aucun problème
aux chrétiens de défiler avec le
hezbollah et ils se défendent d'être pro
syrien
résistance libanaise en face du cn
je ne sais jamais tourné contre son
peuple de la tyrannie sur ma peau je ne
vais pas être interlocuteur avec tout le
peuple du mali
d'après les sondages l'alliance des
chrétiens down et du hezbollah
représenterait 70 % des libanais on dire
au gouvernement qui va être déchues dit
que nous sommes la majorité réelle à la
tribune le général aoun a demandé un
gouvernement d'union nationale
quelques milliers de manifestantes
installé des tentes pour dormir ils ne
quitteront la place que lorsque le
gouvernement sera tombée c'est la
première fois que des chrétiens et des
cheats défilent ensemble dans le même
camp et c'est un événement important
aujourd'hui au liban les lignes de
fracture ne sont plus vraiment
religieuse et politique
on peut y voir un espoir aussi bien
qu'avant au liban où ségolène royal pour
le deuxième jour de sa visite s'est
rendu dans le sud du pays au qg de la
finul la candidate socialiste à la
présidentielle devrait rencontrer ce
soir les parlementaires libanais de la
commission des affaires étrangères sur
place j'ai vite heimberg olivier robert
et pendant ce temps la candidate
socialiste poursuit sa tournée au liban
pas n'importe quelle étape aujourd'hui
le sud du pays où sont stationnés les
1600 casques bleus français
la fille d'officier n'a pas l'air
dépaysé dans ce quartier général les
soldats de la finul jusque là habitué à
michèle alliot-marie découvre une autre
femme qui s'intéressent à la candidate
ne se contentera pas d'une revue et
d'une photo avec les troupes le général
pellegrini qui commande l'unité lui a
parlé des survols de l'armée israélienne
alors ségolène royal a donné sa ligne
j'ai bien l'intention et d'en parler aux
dirigeants israéliens genre axé sur vols
doivent cesser parce que c'est à la fois
l'intérêt d'israël et l'intérêt du liban
autre ambiance militaire les blindé
libanais protégeant les points
névralgiques de beyrouth de la
manifestation ségolène royal n'a rien
changé à son programme et à l'ambassade
de france sous le regard de
l'ambassadeur elle expose encore ses
idées
pourquoi pas une rencontre avec le hamas
quand elle sera en territoire
palestinien
je suis en phase avec la politique
actuelle de la france au liban
c'est à dire j'ai pu rassurer mes
interlocuteurs sur la continuité de la
politique française
et quand ce soir ségolène royal
rencontre des parlementaires libanais il
y as parmi eux ali amar député du
hezbollah
décidément ségolène royal ne
s'embarrasse pas de précautions elle n'a
rien voulu modifier de son programme
prévu au liban et elle a sermonné les
autorités israéliennes au risque d'être
accueillis fraîchement à jérusalem dans
deux jours bref elle reste fidèle à ce
qui fait sa marque depuis des mois elle
bouscule les habitudes
c'était hier soir sur france 2 nicolas
sarkozy candidat déclaré à la
présidentielle veut être celui qui peut
faire reculer les injustices en france
il a exposé dans l'émission d'arlette
chabot à vous de juger son programme
celui d'une rupture tranquille avec un
ton plus apaisé pour cette entrée
officielle en campagne nickel dame
direction le plateau à vous de juger
pour les couloirs de france 2 nicolas
sarkozy concentré un peu tendu s'apprête
à prononcer la phrase qu'il a en tête
depuis tant d'années
oui je serai candidat à l'élection
présidentielle c'est une décision que
j'ai mûrement réfléchie c'est une
décision qui m'engage je veux que les
français retrouvent confiance dans la
parole politique dans les hommes
politiques pendant presque trois heures
nicolas sarkozy présente sa rupture
tranquille inspiré du slogan de françois
mitterrand il veut dépasser les clivages
traditionnels alors ap je crois en
l'ordre mais je n'accepte lors que s'il
est en mouvement
j'aime ces deux choses le mouvement et
l'ordre faire évoluer son image et
changer de registre le candidat sarkozy
propose sa révolution économique
il faut donner du pouvoir d'achat aux
français pour donner de la croissance et
pour cela il faut permettre aux gens de
travailler plus politiques nicolas
sarkozy se veut adepte du parler vrai
pas de régularisation massive s'il est
élu suspension des négociations avec la
turquie et nous sont revanche on note un
recul sur le projet de droite grotte aux
immigrés pour les élections locales dans
deux générations
par ailleurs nicolas sarkozy qui veut se
montrer ouverts ne rejette pas l'idée
d'une candidature de michèle alliot
marie
si michèle alliot marie est candidate ça
sera très bien pour la démocratie
interne c'est une personne de très
grande qualité tout en ménageant
ségolène royal est la rose et un angle
d'attaqué est ce que vous pensez
vraiment qu'un président de la
république peut se contenter de dire aux
français je vous écoute qu'est ce qu'on
fait talent hier nicolas sarkozy a tenté
de gommer son image de fonceur et de
nervosité qui le montrent parfois il
sait que toutes les campagnes
présidentielles sont basées à la fois
sur l'idée du changement et sur celle de
la continuité
et c'est cette synthèse que le candidat
nicolas sarkozy doit désormais trouver
pour cette première journée deux
candidats désormais déclaré nicolas
sarkozy était d'abord à marseille où il
s'est engagé sur la tva à 5 5% pour les
restaurateurs s'ils étaient à l'elysée
nicolas sarkozy qui ensuite s'est rendu
à angers où il tient en ce moment même
un meeting avec pour thème principal
l'éducation nouveau rebondissement dans
la fusion suez gdf le conseil
constitutionnel a bien validé la
privatisation du groupe mais en fixant
le calendrier à juillet 2007 l'échéance
est donc repoussée après les élections
présidentielles autant dire que le
dossier sera dans les mains du prochain
gouvernement
derniers développements dans ce dossier
décidément complexe d'un semblant
fourcade et philippe chasselas la fusion
suez gdf semblait avoir surmonté tous
les obstacles les manifestations dans
sont pas venus à bout pas plus chaque
que la bataille parlementaire et sa
guerre d'usure avec 137 mille
amendements déposés par l'opposition
mais il ya une semaine premier accroc la
justice demande à gaz de france de
revoir sa copie car les syndicats n'ont
pas eu toutes les informations
nécessaires
dernière étape celle du conseil
constitutionnel hier ils valident la
privatisation préalable à toute fusion
mais précise que la privatisation ne
pouvait produire ses effets avant
juillet 2007 quand l'ouverture à la
concurrence européenne sera totale et à
cette date les cartes risque d'avoir été
rebattues le plus important c'est que
cette fusion quoi qu'il arrive doit être
remise après les élections
présidentielles et la vie dans
l'incertitude grandit puisque on parmi
les deux candidats les plus sérieux
gagnent à un mois une qui refusent fois
semblement 7 cette fusion donc à ce
moment là
l'incertitude est de nouveau sûre sur le
tapis le parti socialiste et ségolène
royal
opposé à la privatisation de gaz de
france à droite
mystère car si le candidat déclaré
nicolas sarkozy s'est finalement ralliée
au texte c'était le mauvaises grâces et
avant tout pour éviter une crise au sein
de la majorité à paris manifestation des
magistrats et des avocats qui demandent
davantage de moyens ils étaient 400 sur
les marchés du palais de justice
ils dénoncent la misère de la justice le
manque de greffiers et réclament en
particulier la revalorisation des
indemnités que leur verse l'état pour
défendre les clients à très faibles
revenus c'est l'aide de juridictionnelle
dans les bars ou les plus pauvres
représentent souvent plus de la moitié
du chiffre d'affaires des cabinets parmi
eux des avocats commis d'office qui sont
payés jusqu'à 8 euros de l'heure
une profession situation précaire comme
le montrent ces portraits croisés julia
delage mathias barrois stéphanie lui qui
est avocate depuis quatre ans dans le
cabinet où elle travaille elle est
chargée des dossiers dette
juridictionnelle bonjour aux fonctions
elle travaille pour les gens qui n'ont
pas les moyens de se payer un avocat
ce ne sont pas les dossiers les plus
prestigieux mais les affaires à défendre
n'en sont pas moins complexe
alors monsieur je vous remets le
formulaire de demande 7 juridictionnelle
quel que soit le temps passé sur cette
affaire elle touchera environ 1000 euros
versés par l'état
c'est le barème et c'est moitié moins
qu'avec un client qui paye sur ses
propres deniers
c'est des dossiers qui sont peu
rémunérateur parce que le barème
d'indemnisation n'a pas été revalorisé
depuis de très longue date mais c'est
aussi un retard très important pour
l'indemnisation des avocats ma défense
par là même avec l'aide juridictionnelle
que sans cette aide alors il faut savoir
que l'avocat qui acceptent d'intervenir
hôtel de type de l'aide juridictionnelle
n'est pas un avocat au rabais l'an
dernier en france plus de 800 mille
personnes ont bénéficié de l'aide
juridictionnelle les environs un avocat
sur deux refuse de la pratique et être
rémunérés par une nature y dictionnaire
c'est gagner entre cinq et dix fois
moins ce que ce que l'on pourrait
obtenir avec un dossier ordinaire de
même nature se serait même pas normal
que des gens dans une situation de
détresse n'est pas de défenseurs pour
les assister alors aujourd'hui les
avocats demandent 15 % d'augmentation
pour l'aide juridictionnelle
pour eux c'est un strict minimum d'un
côté on affiche un accès à l'aide
juridictionnelle important on est dans
le peloton de tête s'est pas contestable
par contre quand on arrive au montant
des rémunérations perçues par les
avocats on est après la lituanie en
grève aujourd'hui les avocats doivent
maintenant décider de la suite du
mouvement
certains boycotteront les aides
juridictionnelles d'autres les
reprendront en attendant une nouvelle
journée d'action prévue le 18 décembre
dans les côtes d'armor à centre leclerc
a été condamné par la justice il lui est
reproché d'avoir fichiers de façon
illégale des clients mauvais payeurs une
pratique qui doit avoir l'autorisation
de la cnil la commission nationale de
l'informatique et des libertés
éric pineault gabriel kenya guillemette
larrère vient d'obtenir 500 euros de
dommages et intérêts un peu court au vu
de ce qu'elle qualifie comme une
atteinte grave à sa liberté
le 9 octobre 2005 une caissière de ce
supermarché de lannion lui refuse son
chèque
motif elle est fiché comme d'autres
clients jugés non solvables par la
société qui gère le magasin c'est vrai
elle avait fait un chèque en bois mais
c'était en 1999 chez plon
c'est fou hein parce que j'étais
persuadé je savais pertinemment que le
chèque que j'aime et et 240 euros
étaient en europe dès le lendemain matin
à huit heures du matin on me reproche
mon passé un reproche illégal la
commission nationale informatique et
libertés contrôler ce genre de fichier
dans un cadre très strict ici il n'est
pas respecté la liste nord peuvent être
constitués dans la mesure où les clients
sont informés
parce que si les clients ne sont pas
informés ne peuvent pas exercer leurs
droits en cas de difficultés et par
ailleurs il faut que le commerçant
respecte le principe fort du droit à
l'oubli dès lors que la personne à
régulariser son paiement elle doit être
des fiches est ce que la loi ne précise
pas en revanche c'est de quelle façon
les personnes fichées doivent en être
avisé résultats l'information est le
plus souvent très discrète si j'étais
responsable d'un magasin eh bien je
procéderai par voie d'affichage à
l'intérieur du magasin dans l'entrée
pour que les gens le sachent
le magasin a aussi été condamné à 1500
euros d'amendé n'a pas souhaité apporter
de commentaire guillemette larrère a
fait appel elle espère mobiliser
d'autres personnes fichées à tort
journée mondiale de lutte contre le sida
une épidémie en constante progression
avec des chiffres qui montrent l'ampleur
du désastre près de 3 millions de
personnes sont mortes du sida dans le
monde cette année dont 400 mille enfants
aujourd'hui à travers la planète 40
millions de personnes vivent avec le
virus jacques chirac inauguré ce matin
une stèle à la villette a mis en garde
contre la banalisation de la maladie en
france près de 7000 nouvelles
contaminations l'an passé c'est dire que
l'épidémie reste à un niveau élevé les
femmes représentent 40% des nouveaux
séropositifs vivre avec le sida avec les
effets de la trithérapie apprendre à
vivre au quotidien
lorsqu'on est séropositif et pourquoi
pas créer une famille des jeunes femmes
qui aborde la maternité avec confiance
même si le risque de transmission du
virus de la mère à l'enfant est de 1
pour cent des couples qui ont décidé
d'assumer malgré les préjugés nathalie
sapina frédérick basile
un enfant comme les autres
il fête son premier anniversaire un
petit garçon en pleine santé même si
même séparent en effet trop positifs
lorsque mon fils aîné moi je suis parti
avec lui dont pour lui donner son
premier bain comme tous les bébés et
après j'ai pris une petite seringue avec
du rétro vivre dedans un médicament d'un
des premiers médicaments utilisés pour
soigner ses de soigner le vih et je vais
donner quelques gouttes de ça et c'est
un sirop on est censé donner pendant
quatre ou six semaines ce protocole est
psychiatre
le petit nabil n'a pas été affecté comme
lui 1500 enfants naissent chaque année
de mères séropositives risque de
transmission -2 1% alors qu'il ya encore
13 ans 30% des enfants naissaient
contaminés aujourd'hui les femmes
reçoivent tout un traitement pour
l'accouchement le moment le plus
critique on renforce la surveillance de
france afin de dépister tout élément qui
nous ferait penser que le travail ait
suscité de commencer dans un délai
proche de façon à mettre en place une
perfusion antirétroviral et séance en
cela que la prise en charge est
particulière quand c'est le père qui est
séropositif la fécondation in vitro est
indispensable le sperme doit être
débarrassé du virus problème il n'y a
que onze laboratoires agréés pour le vih
l'attenté parfois décourageante et des
régions comme la région nord par exemple
c'est pas du tout couverte donc tous les
patients viennent sur paris ou dans
d'autres centres de province qui
engorgent encore plus hasina est
séropositif depuis 15 ans elle élève
seule ses quatre enfants de 16 à 3 ans
tous négatifs
une femme énergique qui n'a jamais
courbé l'a7 malgré les préjugés
j'ai pris la décision de me battre c'est
pas les adolescents qui m'ont donné et
les deux petites que j'ai actuellement
qui sont plein de vie
quinon qui connaissent pas encore ce que
c'est la honte lâche ou mac les deux
adolescents connaissent déjà ça c'est
toujours tabou de parler avec eux
aujourd'hui je prends un risque parce
que j'ai des enfants qui vont à l'école
demain matin peut-être des parents
diront propres
propres enfants je veux plus qu'il
fréquente ses enfants mais tout à
ressasser la vérité sort de la bouche
des enfants et moi je me laisserai pas
faire j'irai voir les devants pour
changer le regard sur le sida reda ça
qui a créé une association et anime une
émission de radio pour les familles
séropositives
aujourd'hui 150 mille personnes vivent
avec le vih dont un tiers de femmes
sachez enfin qu'à partir d'aujourd'hui
des préservatifs à 20 centimes d'euros
sont disponibles un peu partout en
france dans les pièces que les bureaux
de tabac les pharmacies et les lycées
pour que l' usage du préservatif
devienne un réflexe
chaque jour ou presque l'enquète sur la
mort de l'ancien espion russe connaît de
nouveaux développements aujourd'hui on
apprend qu'un deuxième homme aurait été
contaminée par du polonium 210 il s'agit
de l'italien mario ce caramel acquis et
avait rencontré l'ex agent secret yamoo
à maryse burgot si l'afer litvinenko
était un puzzle la pièce maîtresse
aurait peut-être celle ci ces avions qui
ont volé entre moscou et londres ont été
contaminés au polonium 210 ce qui
accrédite la thèse d'un lien avec moscou
mais une pièce venue d'italie s'ajoute
ce soir au puzzle elle porte le nom de
mario ce caramella selon une chaîne
anglaise lui aussi a été empoisonné par
ingestion au polonium 210
cet homme au parcours improbable est un
expert en sécurité
il est ce soir traité dans l'hôpital où
litvinenko est décédé
le 1er novembre dernier il a rencontré
litvinenko dans ce restaurant japonais
il voulait dit-il lui expliquer qu'ils
étaient tous les deux les cibles des
services secrets russes
ces empoisonnements sophistiqué rappelle
évidemment l'époque des meurtres
commandités de dissidents pendant la
guerre froide une spécialité soviétique
qui pourrait bien avoir survécu à l'ex
urss
les russes ont gardé une très bonne
connaissance des armes biologiques et
des poissons à quelque chose pour les
sens incroyable coïncidence et ancien
premier ministre russe venu récemment en
irlande est lui aussi malade lui aussi
empoisonné
mais il n'est pas perçu comme un
opposant acharné au régime de poutine
comme l'était liting quo dans ce
brouillard de polonium les enquêteurs de
scotland yard se dirige donc
progressivement vers moscou
mais qui à moscou il ya sans doute
autant de pistes que d'officine de
sécurité concurrentes en russie autant
de pistes que deux clans politiques
rivaux en russie personne ne sait si
fidel castro fera une apparition
publique demain à la vanne pour le
défilé militaire qui célèbre les 80 ans
du dirigeant cuba la havane transformer
en rendez vous des altermondialistes et
des sympathisants du lider maximo sur
cuba souffle une véritable caste romania
alan seulement sur place
fidel castro est sans doute là quelque
part dans la cité interdite de la havane
siège du comité central du présidium et
du gouvernement
personne ne l'a vu depuis cette brève
apparition télévisée en octobre deux
mois après son opération des intestins
l'incertitude créée par son
hospitalisation après 47 ans de règne
sans partage provoque une sorte de
fidèles magna insidieuse ou délibérée
colloque organisé pour célébrer la
pensée du lider maximo sorte de
cérémonie près posthume
faisons une ovation amoureuse à ce
volcan de tendresse qui fidèles demande
la personnalité chargée d'ouvrir la
conférence
la tonalité est donné
le ballet qui suit montre la lutte
héroïque des paysans révolutionnaire
dans la plus pure tradition pékinoise
des années soixante dix
dans les rues de la havane
géré par les comités de quartier du
parti l'heure n'est pas à la
contestation même dans ses boutiques à
moitié vide où l'on vient avec son
livret de rationnement on les aime
énormément fidèles parce que grâce à lui
on à l'éducation et la santé gratuites
beaucoup de choses gratuites fatou
l'essentiel pour la maison on est tous à
égalité et dans les campagnes où les bus
sont encore tiré à cheval où l'on
travaille dur la terre courbé en deux où
les conditions de vie paraissent
particulièrement difficile et bien c'est
le même discours
matériellement nous sommes pauvres mais
en connaissance dans l'éducation en
clôture nous sommes riches soir je pense
donc qu'on est des privilégiés
difficile de dire la part d' attachement
réel des cubains à ce commandant en chef
omniprésent et la part de discours
convenus a pris depuis le plus jeune âge
pour les dissidents comme ces dames en
blanc épouses des prisonniers politiques
qu'il n'y a guère de doute
le gouvernement a le pouvoir absolu sur
tous personne n'a le droit de s'exprimer
personne ne peut changer d'école ou de
travail
tout le monde doit faire ce que le
gouvernement décide il y à un point en
tout cas sur lequel tout le monde est
d'accord c'est qu'après fidèles plus
rien ne sera comme avant
mexique le nouveau président felipe
calderon a prêté serment aujourd'hui
dans une ambiance surchauffée les
députés et sénateurs de gauche continue
de contester sa victoire et en sont
venus aux mâts dans la salle du congrès
à moins de deux heures de l'investiture
la fin du voyage du pape benoît 16 qui a
quitté la turquie avec l'espoir que sa
visite et favoriser le dialogue entre
les religions
benoît 16 a lâché des colombes dans le
ciel d'istanbul et lancé un nouvel appel
à la liberté religieuse tragique bilan
philippines où le cyclone du rihanna
provoqué de gigantesques coulées de boue
plus de 500 personnes sont mortes ou
portées disparues
christelle bertrand
dorian quatrième typhon en trois mois à
s'abattre sur les philippines le vent a
parfois soufflé jusqu'à 225 km heure il
est accompagné de pluies diluviennes
c'est le centre du pays le plus dévasté
ici des tonnes de boue bellay de cendres
ont dévalé les pentes du volcan et
enseveli plusieurs villages les morts se
comptent par centaines
et le bilan est loin d'être définitif
dans les villes les autorités avaient
prévenu la population de l'arrivée du
cyclone près de 14000 personnes non plus
à temps se réfugier dans des bâtiments
en dur
les secours sont débordés par l'ampleur
inattendue des dégâts il n'y a plus
d'électricité ni de téléphone
les routes impraticables ne permettent
pas aux secours d'atteindre certains
villageois encore isolées dans le reste
de l'actualité en france le marché de la
plaisance est au beau fixe un marché en
pleine expansion
à l'occasion de l'ouverture demain du
salon nautique à paris les bateaux à
moteur sont en vedette et les
constructeurs français passaient
l'offensive genia boullemant emmanuel
maurel perdue au milieu de l'océan ce
bateau à moteur semble presque petit une
fois en gros plan
c'est une autre histoire 15 mètres de
long 4 de large
un de ces géants des mers qui a le vent
en poupe en ce moment
c'est l'un des plus grands navires du
salon nautique de paris
une nouveauté française très attendues
sur le salon sais comment c'est
magnifique
même si les grands
oui c'est un beau rêve c'est vraiment
très crue ça reste un rêve un rêve toute
option écran plat escamotable cuir à
profusion bois précieux toit ouvrant
électrique et surtout logement intégré
pour la nex malgré ses six cent mille
euros malgré sa taille ce bateau
s'adapte à la demande des acheteurs
ils en veulent toujours plus les clients
que l'on retrouve sur ce bateau là
aujourd'hui avait il ya cinq ans après
mes bateaux d'une dizaine de mètres un
bateau luxe construits à la chaîne ce
chantier utilise des techniques de
production issus du monde de la voile
domaine dans lequel la france est leader
un transfert de technologie et une
équipe dédiée dix personnes sont
affectées à ce joyau et il faut bien
cela pour exporter matin qu'un marché
non plus un franco français mais marché
européen
donc là il nous fallait des produits qui
attaque déjà une concurrence très forte
estime l'un et puis nous on chez
jeanneau on al'avantage de concerts en
série résultat 20 % moins cher que la
concurrence
objectif de ce constructeur vendre une
vingtaine d'unités l'année prochaine les
futures commandes auront lieu au salon
nautique
ceci nous amène l'ouverture du salon de
la piscine à paris sachez que les ventes
de ce parent doublé en cinq ans à
marcher toujours haut de gamme qui se
développe un peu partout en france avec
ou sans soleil muriel la saga olivier
kohn virginie laurent banquet se sont
décidé l'été dernier pour l'achat de ce
spa et surtout pour moi à oui voilà un
glissement des nouvelles partout et
c'est vrai que quand tu es mars ajoute
ça c'est vraiment le mondial raymond
aussi un tango sportif ça me quand je
rentre dans l'entraînement je fais du
vélo c'est bien agréable haut niveau
aller boire une eau très chaude quelle
que soit la saison
des massages par hydro gmm la musique
qui va avec
grâce à ses enceintes intégrées un
investissement important mais la quête
du bien-être ne semble plus avoir de
prix chez ce spécialiste du spa la gamme
s'étend de 6000 à 24000 euros
comme ce modèle grand format moins cher
celui-ci conçu pour quatre personnes
c'est pas très conviviale avec des
places des portes et vous voyez et avec
un homme de massages de réflexologie au
centre
malgré ces prix encore peu démocratique
le spa est de plus en plus tendance plus
57% de vente en france entre 2001 et
tout le monde veut goûter au plaisir
dans la mesure de ses moyens pensent les
gens on recherche une chercheuse
bien-être ce thème le temps de faire du
sport de se détendre et cherche vraiment
un produit de bien être au quotidien et
pour mieux convaincre le client rien de
tel qu'une immersion totale
c'est pas la 10e
en latin ça signifie le soin par l'eau
et non pas bain de jouvence
malgré les apparences de la boxe avec au
palais omnisports demain sur le ring
brahim asloum qui affrontera bercy
l'espagnol lozano pour asloum c'est le
retour un an après son échec aux
championnats du monde il fait refermera
la roue tourne vite marque de la gana
guèye préparez vous à entrer dans la
peau de brahim asloum l'expérience en
clair
grâce à cette caméra fixée sur notre
champion devenait à votre tour les gars
de croquis asloum vivre les portes de
son entraînement mais vous ne l'aimez
toujours pas d'accord
essayez donc de le mettre au tapis
gauche droite droite gauche à soum danse
autour de vous la vista comprenez le
coup d'oeil
c'est justement ce qui a permis au
français de décrocher l'or olympique à
sydney en 2000 c'est aussi ce qui lui a
manqué il ya un an un soir de décembre
pour devenir champion du monde
paroles d'un homme blessé
à compter sur moi j'ai plus ou moins
échoué - mon contrat mais je suis fier
d'être à la hauteur
c'est le buzz
brahim asloum vit sa première défaite
comme un traumatisme
la déprime pour s'en sortir il plaque
tout et fait son sac
le panama l'argentine et las vegas seul
sans amis ni famille ni entraîneur dans
la capitale mondiale de la boxe part
dans un pays où l'on connaît pas une
langue qu'on ne maîtrise pas super bien
des gens qu'on ne connaît pas du tout
par entre guillemets mais dans la merde
quoi mais cela aussi sortir et le
meilleur de moi même
ici on s'entraîne à l'ancienne le
gymnase est un hangar sans douche ni
vestiaire de la technique de la tactique
pour une nouvelle box
résolument plus offensive demain soir à
soum affrontera lausanne où l'espagnol
que le français avait battu pour être
sacré champion olympique repartir du
début pour mieux réécrire l'histoire
avec cette fois ci en dernier chapitre
un titre de champion du monde
théâtre avec dolores claiborne la pièce
de stephen king d'abord adapte austin au
cinéma aujourd'hui c'est michel
berniquez incarne le rôle un rôle à
contre-emploi marie-hélène bono
frédérick basile
quand michèle bernier fait son entrée au
théâtre dans la cour des grands elle
choisit stephen king pas
particulièrement connu pour ses textes
comiques regarde comment de le reste les
bornes c'est elle elle se vieillit pour
interpréter une femme accusée du meurtre
de sa patronne
une femme battue pendant des années par
un mari alcoolique jaloux voleurs
l'histoire se déroule sur 30 ans on
revit les années de mariage de dolores
êtes-vous jamais de moi crevure je suis
allé chercher dans au fond de moi les
émotions qu'ils ont toujours été cachée
c'est sûr mais c'est en même temps je me
sens je me sens pas non plus partie vers
un ailleurs totalement étranger à moi
parce que c'est je sais pour que la
maturité à mensah et c'est un personnage
populaire stephen king c'est un auteur
populaire et moi j'aime ça au service de
madame donovan elle doit se plier à ses
caprices qui ont séché dorin draps qui
sèchent à l'extérieur retient que du
vent qui l'a souhaité il en a plein
et de fait partir de vos rêves et qui
complète les poteaux nous leur est at
elle aussi tué son mari il ya 30 ans est
tué m règle dans 6 [ __ ] cette histoire est
écrite comme un roman policier
chacun porte en lui des secrets à
commencer par cet époux qui mourra au
fond d'un puits j'estime que c'est
plutôt une blessure qui s'exprime à
travers sa violence qu une méchanceté
c'est quelqu'un qui n'a pas eu la chance
d'avoir une éducation et qui n'a fait
que reproduire ce qu'on a dû lui faire
quand il était gamin
michèle bernier sur scène pendant
presque deux heures démontrent qu'elle
peut susciter d'autres émotions que leur
île les déchirer tout le monde se
souvient de son tube qu'elle
interprétait avec youssou ndour depuis
la chanteuse suédoise a marqué une pause
pour se consacrer à sa famille elle
revient avec un nouvel album au niveai
les news à thierry breton le visage
anges
nick n'a pas pris une ride pendant dix
ans se cachait volontairement et puis
soudain il réapparaît le visage chéri de
toute une génération
en 1994 ou soul tour succombant
seulement sept secondes
quelqu'un
m
ses 25 ans et le monde appartient à
neneh cherry aujourd'hui la jolie
suédoise de passage à paris nous
accueille dans l'appartement d'un ami
son mari cameron est là son mari qui est
aussi son pygmalion
or la vie ensemble ils ont constitué un
groupe circus
m
quand j'ai arrêté je me sentais vraiment
fatigué et las à tout point de vue être
aujourd'hui dans un groupe avec ses
musiciens travaillaient de façon
collective me correspond bien plus
mais comme à ses débuts neneh cherry
désire toujours sensibiliser le public
sur la pauvreté dans le monde
c'est ce que nous disons à travers nos
chansons contre la pauvreté on fait ce
qu'on peut mais en fin de compte on
s'aperçoit qu'on n'est qu'une goutte
d'eau dans l'océan
disons passait rien n'a changé neneh
cherry va bientôt sortir trois titres
avec youssou ndour l'afrique dans le
coeur le hip hop dans les veines son
retour est le signe au sein d'un groupe
dans la discrétion
cherry n'a de toute façon pas besoin des
paillettes du showbiz pour être une star
fin de ce journal je vous remercie de
votre attention tout de suite la météo
nathalie rihouet suivi du poireau de
valérie maurice matte eur55 le grand
moment présenté par mireille dumas une
émission consacrée aux ben-hur de
roberson quant à moi
charles plaisir bien sûr je vous
retrouver demain dès 13h excellente
chanson française
nous
ne
vous